it's always interesting to see what the
media covers when we're out of news will
Michael Jordan come out of retirement
how do low calorie diets affect mice how
bad is Mariah Carey's movie glitter
those were some of the stories appearing
before September 11 2001 they were the
stories being covered when the planes
were in route because we had the luxury
of covering them then BOOM 911 is for
millions a loss of innocence when we all
grew up together in one morning no
longer naive about an evil world
suddenly what we were reading evaporated
with 3,000 lives we felt shame how did
we not see this coming
some people did they were ignored which
is why 17 years to the day we shouldn't
just remember the victims but the
warnings too we can't let those warnings
die from like threats of old mutually
assured destruction is no deterrent for
the murderous martyr the more the
merrier the planet is merely a drunk
tank for heaven a pointless stop on a
final journey technology helps the
enemy's speed up the trip a bio agent on
a drone sent to an open-air stadium will
make 9/11 feel like 9/10 and if it
happens I know what we won't be thinking
about tweets scandals politics and so as
we watch the media obsess over gossip
and palace intrigue remember that
they're missing whatever comes next and
what it happens they won't remember it
themselves because it really won't
matter Donald Trump is in Shanksville
where one of the planes went down flight
93 let's go and play some tape of that
he grieved together for every mother and
father sister and brother's son and
daughter who was stolen from us at the
Twin Towers the Pentagon and here in
this Pennsylvania field we honor their
sacrifice by pledging to never flinch in
the face of evil and to do whatever it
takes to keep America safe
Dayna you been there you went there and
check at the memorial and it's always we
always say that it was basically the
first 9/11 counter-offensive yeah it's
such an Impreza dn't Trump went because
the more people can know about the
Shanksville in the memorial the more
people should go visit it because and
and it's not easy to get to okay there's
a reason that hope thankfully it went
down in the field there wasn't a highly
populated area right there that
Shanksville that the community is so
loving and what they did for the
families there is impressive also at
that memorial gathered every year are
the family members of the 40 victims I
think it was 40 passengers and five crew
or 35 passengers and five crew it's
always so interesting about Shanksville
is that at that memorial you walk and
you can see the field where they
actually made a decision so here's these
Americans they find out what's happening
because they're able to place a couple
of calls back home and they find out
okay
this is what they're going to do and
they're in the back there figuring out
what they could do something but I
didn't tremendous were not able to get
one extra person on that flight they
were supposed to have a certain number
five or six whatever it was they only
got four which meant that there weren't
enough of the terrorists in order to
right track of all of them so they were
able to have this convo
the back of the plane where they made
some phone calls and if you go to
Shanksville you can listen to some of
the voicemails that were left it is very
it's it's touching of course it's
heartbreaking but I think it's important
the thing I love about this flight is
that what you find out is after they
have this conversation they decide to
take a vote mm-hmm about what they're
going to do and that is so American and
they vote that they're going to try to
rush the cockpit and when I remember
when I did the package down there and I
interviewed one of the brothers and he
said that he truly believes that those
who rushed the cockpit on that plane
believed that they might be able to be
talked through how to land it and that
they wanted to come home that night to
be of their families of course we all
know that didn't happen but many people
who worked in Washington DC at the time
credit the bravery and the patriotism of
those flight passengers and the crew
with saving so many life and perhaps
helping protect the cradling of our come
that our country yeah cuz that if it had
gone to the White House which I think is
what they were or the capital either
yeah yeah Jesse I when I was looking at
the stuff that happened before and I was
Michael Jordan and Mariah Carey it
doesn't seem that long ago seventeen
years you say it's it sounds a long time
ago but it it doesn't it seems it's it's
not it's still fresh it's not and for
this generation we have a different
concept of war other generations didn't
have to deal with the idea that there
was an enemy on our soil living amongst
us trying to kill us and we've been on a
war footing since 9/11 and we're still
on that war footing and every day you
hear these lines and they become slogans
but they're not we're the first line of
defense or if you see something say
something and those are actually
literally words to live by because
Americans of all stripes send in tips to
the FBI I think the FBI gets tens of
thousands of tip tips a year which
breaks down to about 40 a day and when
you think about you know they take it on
the chin a lot the FBI sometimes on this
network for some of the political abuses
that they've been accused of and that's
one thing but it's a massive
organization that's just stocked with so
many great Patriots that spend their
whole 24 hours that they're awake trying
to protect us and trying to protect our
freedoms when we wake up in the morning
we're thinking about the football game
or the kids or you know what happened on
TV last night but they're thinking about
how to disrupt plots from terrorists and
it's a whole nother scenario and I love
when 9/11 comes because you're
remembering and you're you know it's a
tragic day but it's a day where
everybody can come together and come
together as Americans and I always think
George Bush was the best president at
that time on 9/11 to guide the country
forward with the bullhorn in the rubble
and the first pitch strike at Yankee
Stadium and his clear black and white
language you to use to rally the nation
was just what the doctor ordered at the
time and he woke every day thinking
about how to protect this country and
that was his most solemn duty and he
really pursued that with a lot of
vigilance and just today I just want to
say you know I'm sorry for the people
that lost their lives and
Shanksville and and in the pentagon and
at the tower's and my heart goes out to
their families and we're never gonna
forget mm-hmm
one I want to just roll some tape this
is the FBI director Chris Rea talking
about current threats cyber and others
today's terrorism threat still includes
sleeper cells al-qaeda all the kind of
major terrorist organizations that you
would think of but we're also very
focused now on homegrown violent
extremists which are people who are
largely here already in the United
States big cities small towns coast to
coast and these are people who are
largely radicalized online terrorism
today moves at the speed of social media
yeah and I mean I think this is a real
challenge for us because all it takes is
one person who's radicalized and has in
go on the internet and find a way to
make a bomb I mean it's chilling well I
mean it's to me it's an idea yeah and so
you have to cope with it as ideological
cancer something that's spreading in the
body of the world the global world as
opposed to just the United States I mean
I was just listening with to Dana and
suggesting and thinking how much at this
moment you we all have a sense of grief
and loss over what happened that day and
the tragedy of it I just hope that as
people look back they don't stop looking
forward Lee Hamilton and Tom Kean who
were on the 9/11 Commission have a piece
and I think there's USA Today today
talking about taking preventive steps
that we have to be vigilant as Americans
and understanding that the idea has
never gone away right and Isis has never
gone away despite claims to the contrary
and that what we know now is that
they're about as powerful as they were
back in 405 and al Qaeda al Qaeda
there's more as powerful as al Qaeda was
then and that they are still in Syria
and Iraq in huge numbers and fighting
this it really takes a lot of money it
takes a lot of people but I think from
the public it takes a sense of not
forgetting yeah and I just I just you
know today when I saw the president
going off on the Justice Department I'm
thinking man stop
stop for a day will ya we don't need
that what we need is for all of us to
say you know what we love our country we
need to hang together and we need to be
vigilant you know Jed I think the
challenge too is it's hard to get the
public to get worried about cyber
threats because it's not as a visceral a
horrible event but you know if they
paralyze the power grid that's where I
mean you're gonna turn America into
chaos I think that that's one thing we
have to worry about and not be
complacent a cyber starts it's
absolutely terrifying the concept and
also the idea of complacency which is
that you hear people deprioritize
national security right now because
there's not an attack happening today
there's nothing that they can see right
after 9/11 I remember everyone
prioritizing national security and
beefing up the military and being ready
for these things and that slowly drifts
away the more time that you have away
from that the problem with that is of
course that you have the FBI as we've
talked about working on things behind
the scenes so just because you don't see
something happening that means that
they're working to make sure that
something doesn't happen they need the
funding they need the backing the other
thing I would say two things
leadership extremely important I also
remember that moment I was working in
New York City I remember seeing George
Bush standing on top of that rubble and
what it told me as a New York City girl
at the time terrified very young was
that I had a president who was going to
do everything he could to put a stop to
this whoever the president is at the
time of these attacks needs to make it a
priority to instill confidence and faith
in people and he did a beautiful job of
that and the one last point is that you
know I was one of those people fleeing
for my life with everyone else and one
thing I remember about that day is that
I didn't know anyone else's politics the
people who took me in I didn't know
where we disagreed where their opinions
were all I know is that we were all
Americans we were under attack and we
figured out a way to come together that
has to be something that happens when
there's not a tragedy or an impending
tragedy there has to be a way to do that
so and we can do it we're absolutely
capable of doing it